of 2022 there are more than 4 billion
active internet users worldwide wow
that's almost 62 percent of the world's
total population on the internet one can
find various type of website full of
information and content so here we are
with the top 10 website which you may
not have heard but are useful brilliant
hilarious and frustrating and sometimes
all at once you are already watching
simply learn but before we begin if
these are the videos you like to watch
then hit that subscribe button and the
bell icon to get notified so without
further Ado let's get started at number
10 we have camel camel camel.com
surprisingly this website has nothing to
do with cameras it's a simple Amazon
price checker then a URL for any Amazon
product and it will tell you how the
price has changed over time you may
realize that you are purchasing at the
lowest price possible at number 9 we
have movieroller.com movie roller is a
self-service mobile app platform that
allows anyone to create and monetize
apps without coding all the apps are
native and work on both Android and iOS
currently the app creating platform has
about 300 000 active users and over 180
000 apps its objective is to create a
low cost app development platform for
small and medium-sized organization
content developers can also create and
monetize their own content apps at
number 8 we have more View mobile is an
AI video generator that can transform
your marketing text into a spooked
person video in minutes you may use
movio to make professional quality films
for Marketing sales training and
learning you should upload your
screenplay and move your will turn into
a professional interesting video mobile
has over 80 AI avatars with various
nationalities Styles and accents the
term electronic Commerce refers to the
sale of goods and service over the
internet at number 7 we have
hackertyper.com hacker typers prank
simulator allow you to prank your
friends and co-workers we make it appear
as if you are coding like a true hacker
simply begin typing enter any gibberish
and it will appear as code in the black
green color scheme seen in every hacker
movie this will amuse and engage you for
few seconds while you pretend to be a
spy hacking just like a character in The
Matrix movie at number 6 we have
copymatic copymatic ai is a Content
generation software that harnesses the
capabilities of gpd3 an open AI natural
language generation model to generate
the next word depending on the context
that the tool is stored with over 50
plus design you can create any form of
content copymatic can be used to write
sales copy product description detailed
blog articles with the blog writer tool
Su meta description testimonial video
script and social media post aside from
copy copy mati can help you brainstorm
blog articles products and product name
ideas execute the appropriate design
from your copymatic workspace at number
5 we have axiom.ai assume.ai allow you
to create a bot for any website without
writing any code now you don't have to
waste time pointing clicking copying and
pasting assume allow you to create bot
without writing code to automate forms
create a board that describes data
presses button and enters content also
to automate and free up your time for
more critical tasks use Axiom no code
Port builder at number 4 we have victory
victory can automatically generate short
highly shareable promotional video from
your transcript content or description
it is a quick simple and inexpensive
very powerful artificial intelligence
automates the extraction of golden
nuggets lying deep within your Zoom
teams and webinar sessions Victory uses
artificial intelligence to automatically
Produce High conversion video sales
letter equipped with stock footage
soundtrack and narration in just minute
Victoria can automatically add subtitle
to your movies quickly effortlessly and
precisely improving brand exposure as 85
percent of social media videos are
viewed on mute number three we have
dubbed a good order okay so this one is
becoming increasingly popular but for
those who are unaware Dr go is a search
engine website comparable to Google the
key distinction with Dr go is that it
neither stores nor tracks your digital
Footprints at number 2 we have
geogassa.com this game is absolutely
fascinating your dropped any place in
the world on Google Street View and must
determine where you are the more you
explore the more points you gain for
pinpointing your location on the map you
also have a choice to make yourself drop
nearby your desired destination for
example state in Europe however to have
a more exciting experience you must play
the worldwide version at number one we
have Dalai 2 when it comes to AI tools
open AI sits on the throne for having
one of the best AI tool present out
there open AI has many useful digital
marketing tools like Dali 2. Dali 2 can
create original realistic images and art
from a text description it can combine
concept attributes and style if you like
this video you may add them to your
bookmarks favorites or even a mobile app
and if you want to master these skill
for free do check out the skill up
platform the link in the description box
below and yes you heard it right these
courses are free thank you for watching
this video till then stay safe and keep
learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here